اعلنت فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه انها
اوقعت اصابات بين جنود الاحتلال في
اشتباكات عنيفه خاضتها معهم اثناء
اقتحامهم مخيم طول كرم فجر الخميس وقد
اعترف الجيش الاسرائيلي باصابه خمسه من
جنوده احدهم في حاله حريجه خلال تلك
الاشتباكات من جانبها قالت حركه حماس ان
المقاومه ثبتت قواعد اشتباك جديده مع قوات
الاحتلال في الضفه
[موسيقى]
الغربيه
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلالات تصاعد العمل
المقاوم وتطور ادوات واساليب المقاومين
الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه في مواجهه
اقتحامات الاحتلال لبلدات ومخيمات
فلسطينيه كيف سينعكس تغير قواعد الاج باك
مع الاحتلال كما تقول فصائل المقاومه على
مزاج الاسرائيليين وعلى شعبيه حكومه
نتنياهو التي تواجه تحديات داخليه
وانقسامات عميقه داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
وما مالات تصعيد اسرائيل المستمر ضد
الفلسطينيين رغم فشل قبضتها الامنيه في
ايقاف المقاومه وما هي ارتدادات ذلك على
المشهد في عموم المنطقه ومسار التسويات
السياسيه
فيها
[موسيقى]
في سياق تطور مضطرد في ادوات واساليب
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه
امام اجتياحات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
واقتحامات المتكرره لمدن وبلدات ومخيمات
الضفه اعلنت فصائل فلسطينيه عن اشتباكات
عنيفه خاضتها مع قوات الاحتلال اثناء
اقتحامها مخيم طول كرم ما اوقع اصابات في
صفوف جنود الاحتلال الذي اقر باصابه خمسه
من قواته ووصف حاله احدهم بالحرجه وقد
اوضحت المقاومه انها نصبت كمينا من عبوات
متفجره عن بعد لجنود الاحتلال عند مدخل
المخيم احداث مخيم طول كرم التي تبنتها
كتائب القسام تزامنت مع محاوله شابي
فلسطينيين تنفيذ هجوم مسلح عند مستوطنه
افني حيفتس قربه الكرم بحسب قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي قتلت الشابين المنتميين
كذلك لكتائب القسام الجناح العسكري لحركه
حماس التي اكدت بدورها ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ثبتت قواعد اشتباك جديده مع
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في الضفه لمنعه
من دخول المخيمات
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا الدكتور حسن
خريشه نائب رئيس المجلس التشريعي
الفلسطيني الموجود حاليا في عمان من
الناصره ضيفنا هو الدكتور مهند مصطفى مدير
مركز مدى الكرمل للدراسات الاجتماعيه
التطبيقيه والخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه
ومعنا من واشنطن الدكتور خليل العناني
استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
والباحث بجامعه جورج تاون مرحبا بكم جميعا
دكتور حسن خريشه هجوم مسلح قرب مستوطنه
اسرائيليه بالتزامن مع كمين ضد قوه
اسرائيليه كانت تحاول الدخول الى مخيم طول
كرم ماذا يقول تقول لنا هذه الهجمات
المتزامنه عن تطور اسلوب المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وعن قواعد الاشتباك الجديده
التي تتحدث عنها
الفصائل يعني ما جرى هذا الصباح هو يوم
كرمي بامتياز بم معى ان هناك شباب فلسطيني
ثائر مقاوم ذهب الى قلب او بجانب مستوطنه
تقع على قريه الحفاصي اراضي قريه الحفاصي
الموازيه او المحاذيه لقريه شوفي وتم
الاشتباك مع المستوطنين باطلاق الرصاص على
المستوطنين ومن ثم الاشتباك مع قوات
الاحتلال بالوقت واستشهد هؤلاء والرحمه
لهؤلاء الشهداء والشفاء للجرحى وايضا في
نفس الوقت كانت قوات خاصه اسرائيليه تقتحم
مخيم طول كرم هذا المخيم العصي على
الاقتحام بحيث ان مقاومين هذا المخيم
الموحدين والمتحد في مواجهه هذا الاحتلال
اوقعوا اصابات حقيقيه في قوات الاحتلال من
خلال استخدام ادوات جديده بمعنى ان هناك
تواصل بعض المقاومين بعضهم مع الاخر وهناك
عمليه تنسيق واحده وموحده وبالتالي هذا ما
يربك هذا الاحتلال على اعتبار انه هناك
تطور نوعي في اداء المقاومه او الفدائيين
الجدد في عملهم ضد قوات الاحتلال ومنعهم
من اقتحام هذا المخيم بالرغم من
امكانياتهم البسيطه وقد اعترف الاحتلال
باصابه خمس من جنوده في مخيم طول كرم
وتحديدا في حاره حاره البلاونه الملاصقه
ايضا للضواحي بمعنى انه الضواحي والكره
والمدينه والمخيم تشترك معا في صد هذا
العدوان الذي تم ا اشاف يعني قوات الخاصه
التي اقتحمت هذا المخيم منذ اللحظات
الاولى وتم الاشتباك معهم وجها لوجه من
نقطه صفر بالاضافه ايضا لاستخدام العبوات
المصنعه محليا وهي التي اذت هذا الاحتلال
وبالتالي هذا رساله الرساله اولا انه هناك
مثلث فلسطيني الان يقوم نابلس جنين كمركز
طول نابلس ثم جن ثم طول كرم وبالتالي هذا
المثلث اصبح مثلثا مقاومه واصبح الاحتلال
دائم الوصول محاول يحاول الوصول الى اقتحا
لاقتحام هذا المخيم لاجتثاث هذه المقاومه
وهو عبثا يحاول في كل مره يقتحم يفشل ويتم
افشال من قبل هؤلاء المقاومين وهذه ضرب
بالصميم للاحتلال طيب سنفصل في ذلك دكتور
حسن خريشه ولكن قبل ذلك دعنا نذهب الى
الدكتور مهند مصطفى لنسال دكتور مهند عن
وقع هذه ال
العمليات في الداخل الاسرائيلي لا سما
الكمين المسلح الذي استهدف هذه القوه
الاسرائيليه التي كانت تحاول الدخول الى
مخيم طول كرم وا
الصور صور استهداف هذه
ال الوحده ونشر هذه الصور بعد اجبار
اسرائيل السلطات الاسرائيليه على الاعتراف
بحدوثه وبان بنتيجته وقع خمسه جرحى اصاب
احدهم
حرجه نعم يعني تداعيات ذلك على على
المجتمع الاسرائيلي وعلى السياسه
الاسرائيليه هو مختلف
ومنوع اولا هذه الصور تكسر الغطرسه
الامنيه الاسرائيليه التي دائما تنطلق من
ان جنودها يدخلون الى مدن الضفه الغربيه
والى المخيمات الفلسطينيه ويخرجون بدون اي
اصابات في الفتره الاخيره نجد ان دخول
الجيش الاسرائيلي الى مناطق الضفه الغربيه
وال المخيمات دائما من كان يعني يرافقه
اصابات وعمليات فلسطينيه نوعيه ضد هذه
القوات هذا معناه ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه
ايضا تتعلم من المداهمات الاسرائيليه
وتطور نفسها وهذا يشكل يعني ضربه للغطس
الامنيه الاسرائيليه التي تعتقد انها
قادره على كل شيء انها تستطيع ان تصل الى
اي فلسطيني في اي منطقه في الضفه الغربيه
هذا على المستوى المعنوي للمجتمع
الاسرائيلي على المستوى السياسي هذه
العمليه هي تؤدي الى احراج الحكومه
الاسرائيليه هذه الحكومه التي وعدت
ناخبيها ووعدت الجمهور الاسرائيلي بقدرتها
على ضرب المقاومه الفلسطينيه على استمرار
الاستيطان بدون اي مقاومه فلسطينيه والان
المقاومه الفلسطينيه دائما في الفتره
الاخيره ليس فقط انها موجوده وحاضره وانما
ايضا يعني ايه تقوم بتحسين ادائها ورغم
يعني كثافه المداهمات الاسرائيليه ما زالت
المقاومه الفلسطينيه مستمره هذا الامر
يؤدي الى احراج الحكومه الاسرائيليه وكشف
انها غير قادره وفاشله على مواجهه هذه
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ضد كل الممارسات
الاسرائيليه في الضفه الغربيه هذا على
المستوى السياسي على المستوى العسكري
هنالك في واضح ان هناك في فشل استخباراتي
فشل عسكري هذا الفشل يعني مستمر كل الوقت
في الضفه الغربيه والنابع ان اسرائيل الان
تواجه عمليات مختلفه عما كان ايه في
السابق عمليات اكثر نوعيه وهي غير قادره
لا عسكريا ولا استخباراتيا على مواجهه هذه
العمليات ونرى ان هنالك في استعمال
فلسطيني للعبوات الناسفه وهذا بدا يقلك
الجانب الاسرائيلي بشكل كبير جدا اذا مثل
هذه العمليات النوعيه الفلسطينيه او مثل
هذه المواجهه والدفاع الفلسطيني الذي فيه
تطور كبير جدا يحرج اسرائيل على المستوى
المعنوي على المستوى السياسي وعلى المستوى
العسكري والاستخباراتي ولذلك اسرائيل لا
تحب ان ترى هذه الصور هي تعتقد انها قادره
ان تدخل الضفه الغربيه مثل اي جوله عاديه
ترفيهيه تدخل وتخرج بدون اي ايه ايه خسائر
الان اسرائيل تعلم ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه
في الضفه الغربيه تتعلم هي في حاله تعلم
دائم وفي ذلك هي ايضا مواجهتها للمدامات
الاسرائيليه في حاله تحسن وتطور كبير جدا
وهذا الامر عمليا يكسر كل السياسات
الاسرائيليه الموجهه ضد الضفه الغربيه
وبالذات هذه الحكومه اليمينيه المتطرفه
الاستيطانيه التي تعتقد انها تستطيع ان
تستمر بالاستيطان وهدم البيوت الفلسطينيه
و وتقليص الحيز الفلسطيني وفي نفس الوقت
ان ان تقمع المقاومه الفلسطينيه وهي بذلك
تفشل المره طلو المره دكتور خليل
العناني من موقع الاولويات التي لدى
الاداره الامريكيه حاليا فيما يختص
ب ما هو مرسوم للمنطقه فيما يختص
ب التقارب العربي الاسرائيلي الذي تشجعه
هذه الاداره الامريكيه كيف يتم
النظر الى ما يحدث على الساحه الفلسطينيه
والى هذا الى الى تصاعد هذه العمليات
المقاومه
الفلسطينيه انا اعتقد ان الهدف الرئيسي
حاليا استاذ السسي للاداره الامريكيه هو
هدف استراتيجي وهو متعلق بتوسيع رقعه
التطبيع بين اسرائيل والدوله العربيه هذا
يعتبر هدف مهم جدا في سبيل ذلك يتم تدليل
كل العقبات المتعلقه بالتواصل ما بين
اسرائيل والدول العربيه خاصه الان الحديث
حول امكانيه التوصل لصفقه تطبيع بين
السعوديه وبين اسرائيل في ظل وجود ضمانات
امريكيه لكلا الطرفين بشكل اوخر لكنه ليس
للاسف الشيد على الطاوله ما يتعلق بحقوق
الفلسطينيين طبعا هناك حاله قلق امريكي من
ان يؤدي التصعيد فيدفه الغربيه لتعطيل
مسارات التسويه لكنه بشكل عام ليس هناك اي
اتخاذ لخطوات عمليه على الارض قد توقف هذه
الانتهاكات نعم هناك نوع من هنا سؤالي
ايضا لو سمحت دكتور خليل يعني كيف تريد
الاداره الامريكيه من اسرائيل ان تتعامل
مع هذه الحاله المقاومه المتصاعده والتي
يبدو انها
تتطور في الضفه
الغربيه هناك مستويين للموقف الامريكي
مستوى على مستوى الخطاب هناك حاله رفض
امريكيه لوجود تصعيد داخل الضفه الغ بيه
المحتله وهناك محاولات للضغط من وراء
الابواب المغلقه لوقف هذه المساله لكن
ايضا من ناحيه الفعل ليس هناك اجراءات
امريكيه حقيقيه مثلا لمعاقبه اسرائيل
وراينا مثلا قبل حوالي اربعه شهور من الان
عندما قامت اسرائيل باقتحام مخيم جنين
اكتشفنا بعد فتره ان هناك تنسيق امريكي
اسرائيل وتغط امريكا كبير جدا في السماح
لاسرائيل بقيام بهذه العمليه التي ادت الى
مقتل العديد من الفلسطينيين وبالتالي
الموقف الامريكي موقف معل قد يبدو متململا
قد يبدو غير مرحب بهذه الانتهاكات لكنه في
نفس الوقت لا يفعل ش على اطلاق ايقافه بل
بالعكس هناك دعم امريكي سواء سياسي
لاسرائيل دعم عسكري كما نعل جميع اسرائيل
تعتبر المتلقي الاول لمساعده العسكريه
الامريكيه في في العالم من امريكا بحوالي
4 مليار دولار ايضا هناك شعور اسرائيلي
داخلي بوجود حاله ضعف الار الامريكيه خاصه
في ظل اولا حاله التمل حاله الترهل
السياسي الداخلي في امريكا في ظل وجود
خلافات ديمقراطيه جمهوريه وايضا جمهوريه
جمهوريه وفي نفس الوقت نحن اذاء موسم
انتخابي ساخن بشكل اوخر تحاول اداره بايدن
ان تقدم نفسها للناخب الامريكي باعتبارها
قادره على ان صفقه سلام في المنطقه رغم
عدم وجود حل حل القضيه الفلسطينيه عدم رغم
عدم وجود اي ضغط لاقام الدوله فلسطينيه
كما كان هو الحال قبل ذلك رغم ان هناك
خطاب معلن امريكي بوجود حل دولتين لكنه
على الارض ليس هناك اجراءه تدعم ذلك
وبموقف الامريكي موقف الحد بعيد يشجع اس
على هذه المساله ليس موقفا رادعا قد يوقف
هذه الانتهاكات الريه بحق الفلسطينيين طيب
دكتور حسن خريشه ذكرت لنا ان الان هناك
ظهور لهذا المثلث المقاوم بين نابلس وجنين
وطول كرم يحاول ان يثبت قواعد اشتباك
جديده ولكن هناك راي يقول يعني ما في ظل
هذا عدم التكافؤ الهائل في موازين القوى
ما الذي يمكن ان تحققه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ونحن نتحدث عن هذه الحاله من
ضمن مشهد اكبر واشمل على الساحه
العربيه من ضمنه هذا التقارب الج
عربيا بين دول عربيه واسرائيل ما الفارق
الذي يمكن ان
تحدثه تصاعد عملي المقاومه في
الضفه يعني رغم فارق الواسع وال الشاسع ما
بين المقاومين والاحتلال الا انه يبقى انه
هناك رسائل ترسل من قبل هؤلاء المقاومين
الاحتلال اولا يستخدم كل الخيارات المتاحه
امامه وهذه الخيارات هي اقتحامات ويفشل
بها ويقتل الفلسطينيين خيارات في القدس
خيارات لاهلنا بال 48 وايضا هناك خيارات
يذهب الى اصدقائه وحلفائه بالمنطق سواء
بالمنطقه او بالخارج من تحت عنوان تهدئه
الاوضاع وبالتالي الاداره الامريكيه تعمل
جاهده من اج بعد قبل خروجها من المنطقه ل
تسيد دوله الاحتلال على كل هذا العالم
العربي وبالتالي تذهب الى صفقات تطبيع مع
دول عربيه لكن المقاومه تقول في رسالتها
الواضحه انه فلسطيني واحد مقاوم واحد
يستطيع افشال كل هذه المؤامرات على الشعب
الفلسطيني وليدرك اشقائنا العرب اي كانت
مواقعهم لانه كل حدا يذهب للتطبيع تحت
عنوان انه لمصلحه الفلسطيني الفلسطيني
يريد ان يتحرر من هذا الاحتلال ولا يريد
لهؤلاء ان ياتوا لزياره السجان وليس
السجين لانه سجين يريد ان يتم تحريره من
الاسر وبالتالي رساله هؤلاء المقاومين ان
كل عمليه التطبيع لن تمر فلسطينيا
وبالتالي وجود هذه المقاومه انا بعتقد
يمنع ذلك المقاومين سواء كانوا في فل في
في فل شمال الضف الغربيه او في وسطها في
كل مكان او في غزه لامتلاك هذه القوه
الموجوده الرادعه لدوله الاحتلال تقول
بشكل واضح انه الفلسطيني دائما هو من يقرر
بهذه بمستقبله ومستقبلنا ندرك تماما انه
لنا بعد عربي واحنا يعني خلينا نقول
امتدادات هي للشرق وليس للغرب وبالتالي
اشقائنا العرب عليهم ان يدركوا تماما صحيح
انهم يستخدموا فلسطين طوال الوقت لكن نحن
في فلسطين من نرسم خريطه ماذا نريد الشعب
الفلسطيني اليوم المقاومه هي لديها حاضنه
كبيره جدا من ابناء شعبنا وهذه المقاومه
ممتده ومجده ومتصاعد بشكل واسع وممتده على
كل الوطن الفلسطيني الارض الفلسطينيه سواء
كان في الداخل 48 او حتى يعني في اراضي 67
وايضا بالقدس وبالتالي هذه الرساله واضحه
انه نحن لا يجب انلا نخجل وحقيقه لا نخجل
ولا نخاف من احد نقول انه تطبيع خياني
وتطبيع اصلا هو طعنه في ظهر الشعب
الفلسطيني بشكل كامل وعلى القضيه فلسطيني
صحيح نحن ك رسميا ساهمنا في ذلك لكن الشعب
الفلسطيني كله بمجمله يرفض ذلك رفضا عميقا
وانا بدي اقول للعالم كله عبر شاشتكم انه
عندما جاء السفير او القنصل السعودي الى
رام الله وكانت في حفاوه رسميه له لم
يستطع الذهاب الى القدس واجل زيارته لان
يدرك تماما ان المرابطين والمرابطات في
القدس لن يسمحوا لاحد ان ياتي عبر البوابه
الصهيونيه الاسرائليه دكور م دكتور مهند
مصطفى الى اي مدى
باعتقادك هذه الحاله المقاومه في الضفه
الغربيه والمستمره والتي تتطور يمكن
بالفعل ان تفشل الرهان الاسرائيلي ا على
هذا الانعدام في موازين التكافؤ بين
الطرفين يعني المقاومه بطبيعتها يعني
تاريخيا وحتى على المستوى الفلسطيني هي
الوحيده القادره اولا على ابقاء الموضوع
الفلسطيني موضوعا حيا ليس فقط على المستوى
الفلسطيني وفي الضمير الفلسطيني ولكن ايضا
على مستوى العالم العربي وعلى المستوى
الدولي يعني بغياب المقاومه الفلسطينيه
يعني يعني دعنا نتحدث عن المقاومه اصلا في
بعدها السياسي قبل في بعدها العملي تنفيذ
على ارض الواقع في بعدها السياسي وجود
مقاومه فلسطينيه هذا معناه ان القضيه
الفلسطينيه ما زالت موجوده وان موضوع ان
هنالك في استعمار استيطاني اسرائيلي ما
زال موجودا وان السكان الاصليين الواقعين
تحت الاستعمار لا يزالوا يقاومون هذا يؤثر
ايضا على المجتمع الاسرائيلي المجتمع
الاسرائيلي يريد ان ينسى ان هنالك في شعب
اسمه فلسطين يريد ان ينسى القضيه
الفلسطينيه هو بنى الجدار الفاصل ويريد ان
ينسى ان وراء هذا الجدار شعب يعيش تحت
الاحتلال وتحت الاستعمار مفقود لكل حقوقه
السياسيه المقاومه الفلسطينيه تذكر حتى
الاسرائيليين كل مره ان هنالك في قضيه
اسمها قضيه الفلسطينيه ولذلك المقاومه
الفلسطينيه على المستوى السياسي لها اهميه
ودور كبير جدا ولذلك اسرائيل تخشاها
اسرائيل تخشى هذه المقاومه وهذه المقاومه
قادره على ان تفشر الكثير من المخططات
الاسرائيليه الاستيطانيه ويعني وعلينا
وعلينا ان ندرك ان هذه المقاومه لو انها
كانت في في اطار استراتيجي فلسطيني اوسع
يعني هنالك استراتيجيه فلسطينيه واضحه
لمقاومه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فعلا وحتما
كان تاثير المقاومه سيكون اكبر مما هو
عليه الان لان المقاومه الان هي بطبيعتها
مقاومه دفاعيه يعني في الطابع الاساسي
والغالب على المقاومه الفلسطينيه هي
مقاومه دفاعيه ضد المداهمات الاسرائيليه
ضد عنف المستوطنين هنالك الان في عامل مهم
جدا يدخل الى الى الساحه وهو زياده عنف
المستوطنين وعملين هنالك في جيش وميليشيات
عسكريه للمستوطنين تحاول ان تهدد الوجود
الفلسطيني الامان الفلسطيني الاقتصاد
الفلسطيني وهنالك في حاجه لهذه المقاومه
لمنع يعني منع هذا الانفلات الاستيطاني لو
ان هنالك في مقاومه فلسطينيه ل لزاد عنف
المستوطنين لزاد استيلائهم على الارض
هنالك في عمليه استلاء على الارض من
المستوطنين بشكل مكثف بشكل يومي الاستلاء
على الهضاب الاستلاء على الحقول الزراعيه
التضييق على الفلسطينيين في معاشهم وفي
حياتهم ولولا وجود هذه المقاومه ل لازداد
عنف المستو وكان لتاثير عنفهم اكبر مما هو
عليه الان ولذلك المقاومه الفلسطينيه لها
اهميه اسرائيل نفسها تدرك اهميه ذلك ولذلك
هي يعني تنفق وتخصص يعني اهم الامكانيات
والكوادر العسكريه والموارد العسكريه
والان تستعمل دكتور دكتور مهند ان هذه
العمليات التي تقوم بها فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه او المقاومين الفلسطينيين في
الضفه الغربيه تحرج حكومه نتنياهو الى حد
بعيد
هل يعني ينتهي الامر عند الاحراج ام تنعكس
بما هو ابعد على هذه الحكومه
لا لا لا يعني قد تنعكس بما هو ابعد لانه
هذه الحكومه المبنيه جاءت على قواعد
يمينيه هذه القواعد لها توقعات وطموحات
عاليه من هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه وهذه
الحكومه اصلا وعدت المجتمع الاسرائيلي
سواء كان اليميني او غير اليميني وعدته
انها قادره على ان تحقق الامن بشكل عام
وان وان تحقق الاستقرار الامني والسياسي
في الضفه الغربيه هي الان تفشل في ذلك
ولذلك هذه الحكومه الان يتم وصفها في
اسرائيل يتم وصفها ان الحكومه الاكثر فشلا
في تاريخ اسرائيل ليس فقط بسبب انها تحاول
ان تغير النظام السياسي الاسرائيلي ولكن
بسبب انها ان هذه الحكومه منذ الانتفاضه
عام 2000 هنا عدد الخسائر الاسرائيليه
البشريه في ظل هذه الحكومه هو الاكبر منذ
عام 2004 ولذلك يتم وصفها انها اكثر حكومه
فاشله في اسرائيل الدكتور خليل العناني
ماذا عن عن الراي الذي يتحدث عن ان ما
يدفع الفلسطينيين ومعظم من ينفذ هذه
العمليات هم من الجيل الجديد من ما يدفع
الفلسطينيين الى هذا الخيار وتبني خيار
المقاومه هو عمليا غياب اي افق سياسي
للقضيه الفلسطينيه ويزداد هذا الافق
السياسي قتامه مع مرور الوقت الى اي مدى
هناك تعامل مع هذه
الفكره لدى الاداره الامريكيه في
اولوياتها ومخططاتها لمستقبل هذا
الصراع نعم القط قطع لكنه اعتقد يعني سمعت
معظم السؤال اعتقد ان هناك ادراك امريكي
بان ما يحدث في الضفه الغربيه لن يقف عند
حد الضفه الغربيه بمعنى اخر بالفعل هناك
ادراك ما بان وجود اال الحكومه اليمنيه
متطرفه في اسرائيل يمثل تهديد كبير جدا
ليس فقط لاسرائيل
لكن اضل المصالحه الامريكيه في المنطقه
العربيه من ناحيه ثانيه هناك ادراك بانه
فشد المسار السياسي خاصه نحن الانداء مرور
30 عاما على عمليه اسل التي فشل فشلا
ذريعا ولم تؤدي ولم تفضي الى اي نوع من
الحل الذي قد يهدئ الاوضاع هناك وبالتالي
المستقبل قاتم جدا هناك ادراك ايضا هناك
فرق بين الادراك وبين معرفه الوقاع على
الارض وبين التصرف من اجل تغيير هذا
الواقع كما قلت قبل قليل نحن اذاء اداره
امريكيه ضعيفه مهتزه وهناك ادراك اسرائيلي
لذلك اسرائيل ت يعني نتنياهو يعلم جيدا
انه بايدن ليس ب في منطق قوى يعني قد يؤدي
الى الضغط عليه من اجل وقف هذه الانتهاكات
هناك ايضا كما قلت انشغال امريكي ليس فقط
داخليه ايضا خارجيا انشغال بالحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا انشغال مع الصين وبالتالي
هناك استغلال اسرائيل واضح جدا لهذه
الحاله الانشغال لامريكا فيما يتعلق
بارضاء اليمين المتطرف في اسرائيل كما قال
الدكتور مهند قبل قليل نحن حكومه يمنيه
متطرفه جت على اجنده تقوم على التخلص من
اي شيء فلسطيني وعلى التمسك بحال المصريه
الكبرى وبالتالي ليس هناك افق للحل في
المستقبل قريب المشكله الرئيسيه استاذه
السسي انه ليس هناك استراتيجيه امريكيه
واضحه في هذا الاطار كما قلت قبل قليل
الاستراتيجيه الواضحه فقط هي تطبيع او
توسيع التطبيع مع اس الدول العربيه لمصالح
استراتيجيه اسرائيليه وامريكيه ايضا لكن
ليس هناك اي تحرك على الارض من اجل وقف
هذه الانتهاكات من اجل احضار او من اجل
دفع الاطراف المختلفه للتفاوض حتى فيما
يتعلق بامكانيه وجود منتدى اقليمي او وجود
يعني كما يطلق على مثلا منتدى النقب من
اجل وجود يعني ضغط على الريل ليس هناك اي
تحرك عا على الارض وبالتالي ليس هناك افق
واضح لهذه المساله هناك حاله ضعف امريكيه
وضحه جدا هناك رهان اسرائيلي ايضا على
امكانيه وصول ترامب مره اخرى للسلطه العام
القادم العام بعد القادم في الانتخابات
2024 وبالتالي هناك يعني تسويف لهذه
المساله حتى يتغير الوضع في امريكا
وبالتالي الفع بتجاه مخططات اسرائيليه
ليمان على الارض نعم حسن دكتور حسن خريشه
بعجاله الى اين تذهب
الامور لناحيه التصعيد الاسرائيلي وناحيه
ايض ايضا العمل المقاوم الفلسطيني في ظل
كل هذه المعطيات في
المنطقه يعني اولا الاسرائيليين يريدوا ان
يهربوا او يصدروا ازماتهم او يهربوا من
ازماتهم الداخليه الى الضفه الغربيه
والمخيمات من خلال القتل والاقتحامات هذا
اولا ثانيا من خلال ذهابهم للتطبيع مع دول
عربيه وتحديدا مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وثالثا استخدامهم كل ادواتهم من
اجل ذلك ورابعا استخدام ايضا الضغط على
اهلنا في ال 48 من خلال ما يصدر اليوم من
قضيه اعاده الحكم العسكري وايضا التجديد
على حركتنا الاسيره الواحده والموحده في
سجون الاحتلال وبالتالي كل هذه الخيارات
تسقط امام المقاومه والمقاومين الفدائيين
الجدد اللي حقيقه اعمارهم لا تزيد عن 22
عاما هؤلاء الفدائيين الجدد موحدين في
الميدان لا يؤمنوا بالانقسام ولا بالنقم
شكرا للاسف انتهى وقتنا شكرا لك لكم جميعا
الدكتور حسن خريشه نائب رئيس المجلس
التشريعي الفلسطيني الموجود حاليا في عمان
شكرا للدكتور مهند مصطفى مدير مركز مدى
الكرمل لدراسات الاجتماعيه التطبيقيه من
الناصره وللدكتور خليل العناني استاذ
العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
والباحث بجامعه جورج تاون من واشنطن وشكرا
لكم مشاهدينا الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء
ه